[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
there's something i wanted to ask you
about
so
yeah rolling in here with this [ __ ]
fake ass haircut but here's the thing
some people you come with a certain
style you get then people are going to
say you're a certain thing it scared me
because it seemed like it wasn't gonna
catch on dude you're over there you got
my hair cut but here's the thing bro
it's not a mullet okay it is a display
of your heart it's a display of your
ambiance bro
it's a display of your freaking virility
you've been doing a lot of new stuff oh
yeah yeah dude it's one of the ways i
totally relate to you i went to bed you
never did show skating did you yes oh
when i watched you on
uh on joe rogan i was like oh my god
dude this guy is like a new haircut new
special
i do notice sometimes like yeah it is uh
like especially on king and the sting
there's it's a fun place where we can
like just rip each other we have other
people like uh we have a little bit of
diversity on there so it's like a fun
place where we can talk about you know
jokes
do do dumb people ever think that you're
mexican yeah wow i'm not saying that
that's sexually suggestive
[Laughter]
do you ever get nervous that when you're
ejaculating a lot of women now will hold
it and sneak off and use it
you know or they'll save it real quick
another person like a heating
environment and then get rid of it later
and it's you know uh
i don't want to say redneck types it's
like a redneck though i think it's kind
of offensive a little bit yeah it's like
you almost have to be
at this i think calling somebody inward
is off limit oh definitely and if you
call a jewish person a money in words
he'd have some probably some [ __ ] in
the something would be in the trunk that
was for sale if he were driving uber
black i'm gonna try to get us tickets to
another fight man and you and i what you
would do is probably you would just take
my hair and then
and just make yours just like mine is
exactly what you do here's the thing
have you ever dealt with erectile
dysfunction
what do you what you don't want your mom
to wake up even though some of the
people's moms probably would have been
but you stood there and looked like you
were upset after they said whatever you
know and you kind of probably went like
that with your hands you know and you
probably can't even move your arms that
high in the air now have you ever been
involved in like drug-induced
homosexuality
you know like where people do enough
drugs that somebody's gay so i've never
done anything gay like i noticed that
we've beco i noticed sometimes at a
certain point there
i just couldn't i don't want my mouth to
be opened by some guy's wiener that's
like technically rape you know if you go
in and you have sex with somebody that
doesn't know you're going to have sex
yeah i can i can't imagine that level of
it at a certain point can having sex
like endanger you if it like gets your
heart real hot you know what else do we
cover everything you've probably been
one of the most requested people we've
had to have on the podcast it was so
good it's also just nice to get to chat
we never really got to sit down and chat
that much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you